well it wasn't quite the landslide that
liz trust might have hoped for indeed in
the polling uh in the run-up to the
votes or during the ballot process she
was at 66 65
the kind of levels that boris johnson uh
secured when he became prime minister in
uh 2019 not as good there for liz trust
by my rough calculation coming in with
about 57 58 of the vote against 42 3 for
rishi sunak so his allies that said to
me it would be closer
are correct but in terms of what she was
saying she promised that she will deal
with the energy crisis she thanked her
supporters and she prayed homage there
to boris johnson which led to a rather
awkward moment where the crowd weren't
sure whether to applaud or not but look
in reality this is a prime minister
facing the toughest entry in over four
decades and that is going to bite
tomorrow when she goes into downing
street and from a party management point
of view she might have been happier with
a bit more cushion with the membership
because the party is deeply divided over
how to handle the economic crisis and
she might have hoped uh for more support
from the membership but there's someone
uh that has a view on that that isn't me
let me bring him in it's brandon lewis
brandon the former northern ireland
secretary could be the justice secretary
uh tomorrow afternoon
oh let's see what the prime minister
decides we've got a new prime minister's
coming into place tomorrow i think we've
so as we said here this afternoon we've
seen actually our party take this
process very seriously challenge the
candidates great depth of talent in the
party and i think that does both well
for the future and brandon lewis just in
terms of the actual result it was a bit
tighter than perhaps uh the liz trust
camp might have hoped for rishi sonic's
team said to me uh over the weekend they
thought it would be a bit closer and she
didn't do as well as boris johnson in
2019 did she do you think it reflects
the divisions in the party i mean what
do you make of the result a little bit
disappointed no it's a good result i
think it's not much not hugely different
concerns roughly where boris was last
time but actually well it is quite it's
about eight percentage different that's
that's quite a lot yeah it's in the high
50s percent which i think is a good
result it's a very clear majority i
think it's one of the things we needed
to see which is good and i think it also
reflects the shared depth of talent
exactly what these trusts were saying uh
just a few moments ago the depth of
talent would cross our party we were
blessing such great candidates actually
right from the very beginning and and
brandon just in terms of the depth of
talent of the party is there going to be
space for rishi's son out backers in the
liz trust administration we know the
party the parliamentary party is very
divided the membership's clearly divided
will she try and reach out to those that
didn't back her in order to try and
build party unity you might not know but
what would you advise well we all want
to see the party come back together and
the chairman said a short while ago
the new leader of our party has just
said party needs to come back together
we are a big wide tent against one of
the strengths of our party i'm sure one
of the things that uh our new leader
will be working with the team through
today and into tomorrow is looking at
how we make sure that all of the party
is reflected across government and
that's one of the benefits of the
conservative party we have this wide
tent that brings together so many views
but when we're focused
didn't do that he had an ideological
cabinet in which he kept other views out
that's fair isn't it and that was part
of the problem with the party i think i
think one of the challenges we saw
through the end of the period of uh
wasn't so much about policy areas but
actually we were still working on living
right manifesto and that's why it's
right we are focused on getting that
manifesto delivered what people elected
us to do is something we all committed
to in 2019. and two more questions
because the thing that everyone actually
watching this today cares about are
their energy bills which are predicted
to go up to an average of
i can barely say three and a half
thousand pounds a year it's like having
another mortgage in october
liz trust what's she going to do about
it i know you can't sketch out the
details but there is talk today about
potentially freezing energy bills
billions of pounds a hundred billion
plus of action to help families and
businesses up and down the land what can
you tell me about the direction of
travel if you can't give me the details
sure i look you absolutely right of
course these things are marketing
sensitive and i can't give the detail
ahead of a fiscal event those people
according to will have very soon what i
can say is it is as a candidate anna's
outlined today in her uh speech
acceptance species the new leader of the
past is very clear she knows this is an
issue we see this in situations like
mining great norfolk great yarmouth in
norfolk where energy prices have been
rising all five central east has been
rising we want to make sure we did it
she has set out a general journey of
traveling it's to deal with the specific
issues people are facing with the
increased cost now as well as the
long-term issues of supply and we'll see
the outcome of that in the next week or
so
tens of billions of pounds well as i
said i'm not going to go into
predictions about what will be in the
fiscal event but in principle she
understands
she gets it she wants to live on this
for people in a way that makes her
material if she doesn't meet the moment
do you acknowledge that she does not
meet the moment on this issue with the
public she is done for it will set the
tone of her premiership and it will
determine whether the public see her as
a credible prime minister that hears
them that is fair and that's why i think
she's so determined to deliver for the
public she gets it she wants to deliver
on that and i'm confident we'll see that
in the week or so ahead brandon thank
you so much for joining us and i look
forward to seeing you walk up down the
street tomorrow afternoon into cabinet
he's not saying a word on that is he uh
brandon lewis there uh he resigned you
remember from cabinet from boris
johnson's cabinet uh he then backed
nadeem zahawi the chancellor in his
early leadership run and then brandon
lewis flipped very quickly to the trust
camp
and is one of her key lieutenants i
expect him to get a pretty big cabinet
job perhaps as i was saying justice
secretary but look you heard what he
said there liz trust here's it and there
will be serious action uh we can't get
ministers to be drawn on the details of
that as brandon lewis said big changes
in uh policy are market sensitive but
let's see if she does meet the moment
it's clear from her team that she
understands the pressure